hi everybody welcome back to true
nintendo treehouse live my name is jc
and i'm joined by some friends i got sam
and i have ethan with me and we're gonna
take you through a little bit of monster
hunter stories two
wings of ruin let's go no right like i'm
actually pretty excited about this you
know i'm a
monster hunter fan myself so again super
big honor um
because you know capcom just recently
announced that the demo is coming so
the demo is coming on june 25 which is
just around the corner
and of course the full game launches on
july 9. so again
super big thanks to capcom for making
this all possible giving me another
monster hunter game to play
um and yeah again for those folks that
are also you know monster hunter fans
like myself
uh stick around to the end because we
are also going to talk about some cross
functionality between monster hunter
rise
and this game so with that being said
uh sam if you please you got it let's
hop in here let's get started
so i've been having a ton of fun with
this demo and i'm really excited that we
get a chance to show it off to y'all a
little bit early before it launches
as we hop in here real quick this is a
great moment to take a look at my
character i did a bunch of customization
before i started the demo
and i named my character after one of
the biggest monster hunter fans i know
so amber if you're watching i really
hope we do you proud and you get a kick
out of this
you can see from my save data i've been
in this demo for a few hours now
and i could actually easily spend
another few hours this is a really
beefy demo experience good news though
is
if you try it and you like it and i mean
it's going to be free in the nintendo
eshop so why not give it a go and see if
you like it
all of your progress will carry over to
the final version of the game so you
don't have to worry about
retreading any ground if you hop in and
check it out
and right here we have loaded into my
house so i'll just give a little bit of
a look around here
as we kind of set the stage for what
we're going to be doing this
is a story driven turn-based rpg set in
the monster
hunter world if you don't know anything
about the monster hunter franchise
no worries we'll be getting you up to
speed if you are familiar
i think you're really going to be
interested in the connections
that you maybe already know from the
game it really draws on a lot of the
mechanics it is the same world you're
going to see the same monsters
but a bit of a different take here and
as somebody myself who really loves
rpgs and turn-based combat this really
suits my game style nicely
you know sam uh jumping in on that i
just want to also point out i think this
might be the first time we're doing live
game play
right it is yeah this is world first
live game play super exciting
uh so here real quick my house is where
i can save the game it's also where i
can do some character customization
my little buddy over here navaroo is a
really unusual very distinctive looking
feline
he's a bit of a world traveler but he
and i crossed paths recently and he's
decided that he's going to hang out and
help me on my adventure so
we will see lots more of him in a bit
but i really want to get out here i love
how cozy it is though in your house like
i
want to hang out in there very much i
will say this game's
art style really speaks to me i think
capcom's done an amazing job of really
making an immersive beautiful world
and as somebody who hasn't had a chance
to get out of the house much lately it's
really nice to have a chance to explore
somewhere that's so beautiful and
expansive
i can talk to people even though they're
not real and have a big adventure so i'm
really appreciating this
uh so here as we take a little bit of a
look around my home village
if you think about monster hunter just
the name of the franchise even if you've
never played you can probably guess that
it's
monster hunter you normally have a
pretty adversarial relationship to
monsters
but that's not the case in this game my
character is part of a community
that has figured out a way to really
live in harmony with monsters
they are our friends who fight alongside
us got a
beautiful kind of housing set up for our
monster friends over here
we even actually if i take a look over
here we just chill on the beach with
them
and i love this little duo they're just
kind of chilling living their best life
here
and my home is honestly kind of paradise
i won't talk too much about
all the different facilities that are
available in my village normally it's a
peaceful wonderful place
but recently things have gone a little
sideways
i am a novice monster rider i'm just
kind of learning the ropes my teacher
over here kana has been teaching me what
it means to be a monster rider
dana what's up she she is amazing and
she's a very good teacher but right now
she's also dealing with the fact that
there are a lot of really unusual
occurrences taking place in
the island we'll talk about the story in
a bit more detail but what you need to
know right now
is monsters are acting very strangely
very aggressively there's a lot of
unusual activity going on around the
island
so on top of teaching you how to be a
monster writer she's also teaching me
how to handle crisis management as we
try to figure out what happened to our
island
because we've had a lot of weird natural
phenomenon and things just kind of
going sideways on us yeah so recently we
found out that there is a poisonous
monster that's causing a lot of problems
in another part of the island so
i recently got back from a mission and
i've been getting ready to head out to
try to track down that poisonous beastie
i hit the quest board over here turned
in a bunch of quests which gave me a lot
of xp for my party
zenny which is the in-game currency and
a bunch of items i then turned around
and used some of that in-game currency
the zenny to pick up some antidotes from
a local merchant
seemed like a good idea since we're
going to be dealing with a poison
monster
uh grab some requests as well so the
quest board's a great central place to
get those but i can also get quests from
npcs around the world
i used some more of that zenny i picked
up to
uh buy some other items that maybe i'll
have a chance to show off here i also
did some crafting so
i used monster parts and materials that
i found around the island and from my
battles to
craft this amazing new sword with the
help of the smithy in town
it's called the chicken decapitator i i
got it which is that we got
we got big chickens is it really chicken
decapitator
it's so cool look at it i just made it i
haven't had chance to try it out yet
i also used some ore to upgrade my
hammer so my gear is about ready
there's one last thing i have to do so
under normal circumstances
and sorry just a moment to appreciate
this little feline in all of his majesty
i would normally hatch eggs before i
turn in quests because i want the
monsters that i've hatched to enjoy the
bonus of all that xp
but i kind of reversed the order here
from what i'd normally do so i could
show y'all a hatching before we head out
into the field
oh just look at this little dude
bulldrone little bulldog he actually i
think got an attack bonus there as well
so he is a new monster to add to my
party i'll just leave his name as
is and for any rpg party mechanics and
party strategy are key and here it's no
different
but the pretty awesome thing here is
that most of my party members are
actually monsters
so here i'm actually going to change my
lead monster over to the new buldrome so
we can see what he's like in the field
and he's hopefully going to have some
fun out here with me as we get rolling
as we head out of the village you'll
notice that i get the option of choosing
to head out in the afternoon or the
evening
so for the sake of this segment we're
going to stick with afternoon departure
times but
i do encourage folks for watching when
you're playing this yourself mix it up a
bit check things out
in the field in the afternoon and in the
evening as we mentioned crafting and
finding those key materials is so
important to the monster hunter
experience and things are going to be a
little different at night so you want to
mix it up a little bit
and before we get rolling here i'll just
take a little bit of a scan around so
you can see the environment
there are a lot of different spots here
in my island home that i've already
visited over the course of the demo
some other places i haven't quite been
yet here behind me you can see navarro
is on the back of the bulldog i just
hatched and there's kana and her monster
companion as well and
we'll do a little bit of exploring here
so when it comes to collecting materials
some like this over here pretty easy to
spot
not a problem to grab that other
materials are going to be a lot harder
to find especially when you're thinking
about insects some of the really small
collectibles
you're just really going to want to dig
into these environments to find all the
goodies
so that you can craft to your heart's
content and while you're doing that you
want to be careful of the monsters
i just wanted to say like we've you know
we've gotten a chance to see you run
around out here before and i just
i love how alive the environment is and
and your point about
you know spotting those those items you
can pick up there's like so
much detail to spot and it really
rewards you if you're that person that
loves exploring every
nook and cranny um you know of these you
know big open spaces
and to jump on that point you know i was
thinking about um you know
coming from the monster hunter right
side i'm a fan right so
i think regardless if you are a monster
hunter fan existing like your current
one that's just really in a monster
hunter or if you're not
into monster hunter at all and you're
interested to get into the series
i think this is actually a really good
game for you to pick up and just to
understand the world
even the cycle of going out finding
stuff and then like coming back and then
crafting
all of those things that whole cycle
still applies
in monster hunter so again great first
point of entry into the series ooh
and um i wasn't going to talk about
these just yet but we kind of lucked out
here if you see that gold pile of rocks
up ahead
that is a rare monster den and it is
going to kill me that i can't go in here
right now because it's not on the plan
for our segment we know about your
completionist
okay so i can talk about it at least so
monster dens are a really fantastic
place to go if you want to fight new
monsters
hopefully find some eggs and build out
your party
some of the dens are persistent on the
map others
are either rare like this beautiful gold
one that's taunting me over here
or they only appear under very specific
circumstances so normally when you play
hit those up every time you see them
because that's the best way to level up
your party and also build up your party
with new monsters sure we can't just
take a peek in there
i want to but i feel like i'll run out
of time if i do
um also over here just to take a look
out
and we noticed this earlier monsters
appear in the field
so i can choose whether or not to
interact with them whether or not to
engage with battle
again if i was just playing this
normally i would be running up to every
single one of these monsters
getting into fights but i have a lot to
cover here so i'm not gonna do that
this time
some of the guys up there were
herbivores so they pretty much leave me
alone but these guys are a little bit
more complicated they're hostile they're
going to come at me
so i'm actually going to use buldrums
dash move and see if i can time this
right to sneak
by them you've got this oh see that
guy's
crossing my path i want them all kind of
clustered up so this is
one of the interesting things about
let's do it
you got it oh come on go go bowl drum
sneaking through there we go okay he's
not easy to
turn he just kind of goes so
oh keep going buddy keep going
all right i think we're good i'm just
gonna there we go okay
straight away here we absolutely want to
think about okay there we go
um we want to think about party strategy
when it comes to monsters in battle and
we'll get into that in a bit
but these traversal skills are also
really important
especially this early in the game i've
noticed a lot of places that i can't get
to quite yet
maybe i'd need to swim or i'd need to
climb but i don't have a monster that
can do that
so i want to think about which monsters
have the skills that i want to use to
navigate the environment and then also
who i want to have in battle
yeah i love that that both sides of
things like you definitely i mean
battles are a big thing obviously as
we're gonna see but
i love that you're also considering what
type of environment
am i in what particular abilities does
you know each monsti have
um and and building that up
and actually that's one reason that i
swapped back over to renmar here so
boldrum was great with that dash ability
for
getting by those monsters but he's still
a level one he doesn't have much
experience under his belt
renmar is really nicely leveled so as we
get into a fight here
i want him in the lead he'll be the
first monster in battle
here we go start talking about some
battle strategy
oh nice okay so we snuck on him so to
start it off here i'm going to keep it
with really basic attacks so we can just
walk through some of the
really ground level mechanics before we
go further the first important thing to
know about this game
is i really only have control over
myself i don't pick the actions for my
full party
if you take a look at the lower edge of
the screen there i can see what each of
my teammates is going to do
if i get a high enough kinship bonus
going with my monster
i could maybe tell the monster what to
do but beyond that really i'm paying
attention to what my teammates are doing
so i can strategize around them
and the next really key element to
combat is this kind of rock paper
scissor mechanic and you can see
an indicator on the left side of the
screen that is a helpful reminder there
so essentially power
beats technical technical beats speed
speed
beats power i love that that icon
triangle because i would totally forget
that
nicely just color coded it's a handy
reminder and for me it's actually my
attack
option because i can do all three kinds
of attacks and
i'm gonna focus the kuliyaku because
he'll be nice and burly and a good
practice monster i know he is generally
speaking a technical type
so i'm going with a nice simple power
attack with my sword
so when it comes to monsters and their
attack types different monsters have uh
kind of a predisposition towards certain
types so kuliaku tends to throw out
technical attacks
renmar tends to throw out speed attacks
but i can't necessarily
guarantee that so i have to allow for a
little bit of
uncertainty here plan a team that's
gonna have some uh good flexibility
and also just pay attention to what's
going on this is not a game where i can
just button mash my way through
right and here you see there's some
bright lines connecting me to the two
monsters that means that
both of them have decided to target me
for their next attack and
another interesting place where the rock
paper scissor mechanic goes in
is if i choose to attack kuliaku and i
have the power
advantage over what's hopefully a
technical attack that that kuliaku
throws out
i'm gonna do more damage okay i'm good
it did throw a technical out
there you can see my power attack beat
the technical so i did a nice chunk of
damage
uh my kinship meter which is the little
blue circle between me and my monster
got filled up
you really want to do your best to
optimize those opportunities pay
attention to the move types also pay
attention to how monsters change up
their move types and
that's something that you definitely see
in any monster hunter game you you can't
just assume what's going to happen with
a monster
and here kuyaku picked up a rock
so and jc like i know when we've you
know we've seen sam do some battling
before and
i love those things you called out that
we're like oh yeah i've seen this like
this is familiar to me right from
being an experienced monster hunter
player so funny that's actually the
first thing i said oh you picked a
problem like that's right he also picks
up a rock and monster on a rise and
if you see a rock you want to do like a
blunt like attack to the front or you
just want to like
yeah see like it's it's all there all of
this knowledge is all the same so again
a great way to prep folks
so again if you're a you know monster
fan like me you'll recognize a lot of
the things they told
like really clever details like that uh
like breaking parts and you've seen the
monster get knocked over and you're like
this is like the
everyone kind of is super excited when
they see a monster get knocked over
because like this is the time for you to
do damage
and that was interesting actually i was
going to smash the rock with a hammer
but ranmar actually did the job for me i
think it was ramar avmar
they did an attack and knocked the
monster prone so they broke the rock
part so now that rock is not a problem
doing work man uh now i can see i can
attack the monster
they're downed so all my attacks are
going to be crits but if i take a look
at the icons that are above the monster
there
there's a line little red dash through
the bludgeoning damage type so
my hammer's not a good choice and i'm
going to swap
back to my sword because i was having
good luck chicken decapitator
yes i mean look at this thing it's
awesome it's huge
and it's flashy it's stylish i'm a fan
and for anybody who's played monster
hunter you know it's
all about getting the gear uh collecting
parts from monsters so you can craft
this really awesome stuff
yeah it looks cool as well as being
functional yeah i love the way
it changes your look and and you get
this whole different vibe on your
character based on the gear they have
equipped
so here we're getting loads of
experience which is great for boldrome
because he's a kiddo he's got to grow up
he's got some uh collectibles and
monster parts and
a really important thing to pay
attention to oh thank you
uh i could get s if i did a little
better but yeah you know talking and
playing is is kind of weird
it's tough um really the goal there is
to really optimize my battle strategy so
again you don't want to battle map
uh sorry button mash through these
battles you want to
think strategically make smart choices
make the best use of your party you can
the more effectively you do in a battle
the more bonus points you're going to
get
try to get up to rank s that's going to
improve the
rewards coming out of battle and if you
really want to bump up your party
thinking strategically and getting those
s ranks is the best way to go
yep now we're back uh let's see here
let's head
this way yeah
you can actually see down here at the
bottom i've got my map indicator
that little dotted line is indicating
where i've been and
it is super helpful uh i will say for
the sake of this demo
i'm beelining it through spaces that i
would normally spend a lot more time
exploring i'm missing a lot of the cool
details because i want to
make sure we get to all of our content
oh they're coming for me wait no no no
no
i can't afford a fight right now you
guys calm down we're gonna
we're gonna try to be sneaky here they
were just excited to see a fellow rand
mario i know hi
stop so happy all right um
oh screw it we'll just see how this goes
come on buddy
amazing okay there we go uh the jumps
the dodges
we're good um oh sorry what i was saying
there was the
dotted line of the map is really helpful
because right now i'm beelining it and
i'm missing
a lot of stuff that i want people to
take the time to discover for themselves
in these areas but
with all the backtracking you can do in
here to find materials and find all the
monsters that are looking in these
spaces
you can get a little lost having that
dotted line to tell you okay here's
where you were
let's try to backtrack is super helpful
and i'm gonna try to miss this
young cocoon sorry dude
i would i wish i could fight you and
take your parts but we got places to be
so you may live yeah this you know the
map is big um
you know getting my hands on it a little
bit i i totally realized like
this is a yeah demo just this is one
little section there's a lot in here
it's just a lot okay so we've found a
monster den
uh we're gonna do some investigating
here see if maybe we can get a bead on
that
poisonous monster that's happening
around this area
so let's see what we got
i here something so i will mention here
i set
the vo to english just in case anybody's
watching today who can't quite pay full
attention to the screen
but you can swap over to the japanese vo
so if you prefer to listen to japanese
voice acting
go right ahead you have your choice of
how you want to set that
and i think oh no maybe found our poison
problem
it's so cute isn't this one of your
favorite monsters
yes uh yeah it's a pookie puke uh so
this monster called the pokey puke
it uh you know it lashes out with its
tongue to do uh
uh you know some attacks it has some
poison to it um
and yeah it's it's like so ugly you
can't help it so it's cute
i'm actually i'm actually working on a
new dance called uh do the puke phuket
oh you're not going to reveal it here oh
man if we had time at the end of the
segment
it could be another world what have i
done
so uh i kind of took a little bit of a
hint there from
uh what navaroo and kana were saying
before we entered in the battle they
mentioned that these guys are kind of
tricky
so i'm hoping that means technically
inclined
and uh looks like it they're generally
throwing up technical attacks here so
oh there double attack both renmar and i
threw out a technical attack sorry um a
power attack against the technical at
the same time
we had the advantage so we did a double
attack but
what i'm actually going to do here is
swap over to bulldrome
because even though renmar is a higher
level and generally speaking does really
well in combat
my buldrome is inclined toward power
attacks which against a technical
monster is going to be a little safer
so i'm going to see how he does out here
he's got some levels now so hopefully
he'll be okay
and kenny using a special attack she's
got the sword and shield combo which is
another slashing
damage type and what's eating
doing yeah it's eating usually that kind
of heals a little bit or it does you
know
or just kind of chills for a bit doesn't
did its face just turn a different color
it's about to use poison apparently so
yeah
that's a thing um i'm actually going to
make a strategic adjustment here oh
i don't know if i have enough skill
energy for it though oh no this is going
to be bad so
my bow here and yeah i'm out of luck
this turn
um if i had enough kinship gauge i would
want to use this absolute evasion move
which i think might help me avoid the
poison
okay i don't have enough energy so i'm
just gonna go with an attack see how
piercing damage works against this
monster all right
keep my fingers crossed that i'll build
up that charge for later you know it's
funny you think you pointed out kind of
like
the face you know turning red and kind
of looking at the monster it was like a
subtle change but
yeah it's actually one of the the things
that i kind of like is you know studying
the monster kind of knowing and
recognizing because right now you take a
look at the top it has like question
marks and like you can't really tell
oh so that's really gross
wow what man oh man okay that didn't
pretty hard yeah look at that
the bow move would have been really good
there i know right now it's kind of back
to normal looking
yeah back to normal so kind of studying
the monster you know taking a look at
the way it feels when it's about to do
something big or
when it's tired all those visual things
will change so again
things you learn either in rise or here
too they're both applicable
and that's something like i've heard a
ton about i'm i'm somebody who has
observed the monster hunter series on
like from the sidelines but i've heard
tons of people talk about it like you
other folks i know um and it's all about
like
like you said studying the monsters and
i love that you know we're in a
different series here but that those
things still apply
um this is the time i've gotten to spend
with snc is like
definitely making me think this is the
title i'm gonna dive in on
oh no oh so there i lost a heart i do
not want to lose all my heart
so let's see how this goes you can do it
sam
i have believe in you yeah you can oh
thank you you have a chicken decapitator
like that
why am i doubting myself it's shameful
um okay here i can choose parts i want
that tail
gone so i'm gonna focus my attacks on
the tail uh right here
kana actually hopped onto the back of
her monster that was because her
kinship gauge was full so she had that
full blue sphere
she's able to hop on her monster's back
do this amazing kinship skill after
which she's going to hop back off the
monster
there's some other really great benefits
to letting that skill charge fill up all
the way
as soon as she hopped onto her monster's
back she went back to full health
her monster got a health boost and they
had some other advantages that they
could have enjoyed there
as well uh we're looking pretty good
i love attack two you get like for using
those skills you get these
cool cinematic visuals that that come in
that just keep these battles so dynamic
um
you know i love turnp turn-based rpgs um
but you know sometimes they're a little
static in in terms of what you're doing
and seeing during a battle i just
love all the different moves you're
breaking out and you get rewarded with
these
these really cool scenes like that and
speaking of i could use my ride right
now
um which would refill my health and uh
give us the ability to do
that that cool ride move of our own
since kana is going to be waiting a
while to do that again i'm just going to
use it now i'm not going to wait too
long if she was close to the same level
of kinship gauge that i'm at
i would probably wait for her to catch
up but
let's see how we go here and if we both
do at the same time
it's actually a really awesome animation
so i'm hoping we work out the timing
here somewhere
go mr pig yes oh heart broken
all right so hopefully that tail means
no more nasty massive
swinging attacks and poison all over the
place yeah it should not after that
all right let's go back to some regular
attacks here so we can see here the
the piercing indicator was uh crossed
out with a red line so
beyond that skill that i'd like to be
able to use using my bow is not gonna be
super effective in this fight
uh the piercing type damage is really
interesting though it's a new addition
to the game
so we've got bows and we've also got gun
lances which we
didn't have in the 3ds game that came
out a few years ago
oh and again can't lose attention
there we go so we've got the piercing
damage
with the bows and the gun lances we've
got oh what do i want to focus on head
well the body's almost down let's do
that
boy so that was a draw slashing damage
with the kind of sword and shield combo
that kana has and
my uh big sword that i'm using and then
there's also the bashing type which is
the hammer
yeah and you see its face is red again
let's see
here she gets angry that it might be
angry
so here as well i can tell what my
teammates are doing so kana
the indicator says she's going to use a
potion and if i take a look at avmar
here his health bar i can tell
that's where the potion is going to go
avmar's going to get the heel so i'm
going to
get rid of that poison on bold room it's
very nice
and i will offer here as we're going
through all these mechanics and layering
it up
if you're somebody who's just like
hungry for battle mechanics and you love
the complexity
you've played monster hunter maybe this
is probably all going to seem very
familiar to you but if you're a player
who's maybe newer to the genre and this
maybe feels a little intimidating please
don't worry about it we are a fair way
into the demo
but uh yeah that's a good they do a good
job with tutorial as you first start so
you're gonna get those layers you're
gonna get taught how to do all these
things and how to build on the concept
so
it's a fun experience no matter yeah i
know that i am
so i have two two daughters and we've
dabbled a little bit
in turn-based rpgs oh dear you're losing
hearts
bad news get up good job
just going to say like i for me a
veteran turn-based rpg player i love the
complexity and depth that we get here
but i'm also thinking that i'm you know
planning on showing this game to my
daughters
um as an entry into the monster hunter
series i love that you can make friends
with monsti's and
and you know there's not as much of an
adversarial relationship so
we're going to play this one together
for sure all right so there we go
doubled up
i really hope this bouquet poop is close
to being done you'll notice the the
health bar actually just has question
marks next to it
uh some of these big boss type monsters
even if i've run into a monster before i
can't assume that they're all kind of of
a comparable level of strength
this guy as jc mentioned in true monster
hunter fashion i hope this helps
oh wow all right there we go um i i
don't know how much damage i've done so
i really have to
rely on those tells as i look at the
monster and watch its behavior
kind of keep my fingers crossed and just
do the best i can with my strategy
and hope i make it and that's because
you haven't fought this type of pk
phuket before
is is that it or well i haven't fought a
puke puke in this demo yet but this
guy's also a
tough guy right right right he's a bit
of a beast and
he's looking a little rough yeah
that's it that's your clue he's close
okay come on it's close
oh that's a good look okay it's tired
we're gonna ride
no holding back just need to take this
guy down
yes oh come on buddy good job
nice critical ah you're still up oh my
gosh
this guy's a beast wow
he's doing the phuket phuket yeah
there you can tell as well i used up all
my skill points on that ride
so i have to wait for it to recharge and
it looks like he's gonna start doing
some poison action again
oh thank goodness okay oh that's a good
feeling my partner
come on oh my goodness yeah
the puzzles there's a lot of puns
there's a lot of them
oh that's right that's right
yes all right then so we've dealt with
the puke puke
i'm ready to go home after this but i i
want to take one little look at this
nest before i make my retreat because
you're basically here on a mission
maybe i can get an egg out of this oh
perfect so
we've got some eggs in the nest and this
is really how i'm collecting new members
of my party
uh by navru's estimation the best eggs
are stinky and heavy
but i like the look of this one and uh
it also looks like critters ran off with
the rest while the nest was unguarded so
i'm just gonna
consider myself lucky and get my butt
out of here before something else shows
up
my hands are full so i can't really do
much else yeah i'm ready to leave
that's so nice selecting leave the
monster then
don't worry you know you know where i
was going with that monster hunter fans
you don't carry it all the way back and
instead of riding
all the way back i'm actually gonna use
a quick travel
tool here to get myself back to the
village
uh if you're familiar with felines from
the monster hunter series you know in
addition to being adorable they offer a
lot of fantastic
like a transport service which is not
the most
comfortable ride but it gets you where
you need to be hopefully your egg is
okay yeah
i hope so oh it's fine it's fine
up here in the upper right i can see
that my next task is to check in
with my chief so i'm going to report in
let him know what we've been seeing here
before we move on
and i'm going to kind of bomb through
the dialogue here just because i want to
make sure we get to all the content
we've got but
the story in this game is really
fantastic it's really worth getting into
and soaking it in yeah because you were
saying i mean these are
not monster hunters they are monster
riders
which was like a distinction that i
wasn't fully aware of before we started
looking into this game
so i love it because i i was always the
kid who loved stories where
you you were friends with monsters and
riding monsters and all that stuff so
this is really
right up my alley so there we found out
that
the chief is going to let me enter
guardian rapha woods and check out
guardian ratha's den to see if we can
figure out what's going on
a really key point here is my island has
long been protected by this incredibly
powerful rathalos named guardian ratha
there's some other interesting story
connections that we'll talk about in a
minute but
long story short this rathalos keeps all
the other monsters in line so if
something happened to guardian ratha
that might explain why all these weird
occurrences are taking place
normally we leave guardian ratha alone
at his place we wouldn't go traipsing
around his camp
but we're gonna go check it out and
they're actually oh this is one of the
visiting monster hunters
so right about the time everything went
sideways monster hunters were visiting
they kind of have some different
opinions uh than we do about what was
happening
um from our perspective maybe we need to
find guardian rafa and work things out
to get things back to normal
from their perspective maybe it's kind
of crazy to have a giant scary rathalos
as your guardian but
yeah you know agree to disagree
now here uh since i downed that puke
puke
i want to fix up my gear that she
suggested that maybe i could be heading
into some trouble here
to take a quick look at weapons this is
a variety of the weapons that i could be
crafting
to look at the types here so we've got
the sword and shields the great swords
the hammers
hunting horns and then the bows and the
gun lances at the end here as well
but i've actually been wearing the same
armor for a while so i'm going to see if
i can get something new
look how many armors oh i know that
looks
nice awesome and the defense is way
better so i'm going to make that
so here you can tell one of the possible
components i haven't found yet but
i need to figure out what i want to
spend
to make up the points that tail is worth
10 points i only need four to make this
material
into armor any extra points get lost so
i definitely want to hang on to that
tail for something big and special but i
can
make enough up with the scales and this
is something that's probably like the
the way that your look and weapon all
that cool stuff changes is probably
familiar to
monster hunter fans but to me coming at
this from like an rpg
fan you know sometimes you get like a
bit of clothing or your weapon
look will change but i love that you get
both you know and there's so
many ways to change up the way you look
i appreciate how that sword
yeah the color scheme is just bam yeah
and also
uh with uh you know depending on the
monster that you hunt they also have
different qualities so the puke puke
obviously has a little bit of poison
so if you wear armor you'll be a little
bit poison resistant but if you have
like a weapon and you craft it out of
there you know
boogie boogie parts then that weapon
will exactly naturally happen
and every monster has its own strength
and weakness so you also want to go
around and basically
uh hunt to your content and kind of uh
get those materials uh to craft as much
stuff as possible so you can really
play into that strategy of crafting your
best loadout
i will say it's hard when you take down
a monster that's maybe harder to find
you've got those parts you have to make
a hard decision about what you're going
to make oh right like am i going to find
another pro
puke soon or do i have to hang on to
those parts and and make the best i can
and
do i want a weapon do i want the armor
yeah that's a tough call but it also
it's like you can kind of decide how you
want to play based on that like are you
a more
attack based you know more aggressive
player or do you want to
shore up all your defenses you know and
you know make sure you have that taken
care of first
i love that that kind of freedom of you
know how you play
and you got to be stylish oh yeah that's
always yeah
i mean i'm sure that's how you play rpgs
right ethan like you
like this looks the coolest it may have
the least amount of like
actual clothing but it's probably the
strongest thing
right and that happens so often weird
inverse game logic
there we go so we are at guardian rapa
woods
uh this is where rafa's den is so we're
gonna do some exploring here and see if
we can figure out what's going on with
guardian rafa
so one of the things that i love about
this game is you can enjoy it completely
independently
so if you've never played a monster
hunter game if you didn't play the
monster hunter stories game on 3ds
it's okay you can jump in and really
enjoy this story as is
but if you've got those connections to
the monster hunter franchise
especially here in this case if you've
played the original mantra hunter
stories on 3ds
you'll pick up some interesting
connections so
my character here is actually the
grandchild
of the protagonist from the nintendo 3ds
game
so my grandfather had some incredible
adventures ended up settling down here
and the adorable little rathalos that he
hatched at the beginning of that game
grew up to be guardian rapha so ended up
being an incredibly powerful monster
my grandfather has since passed away but
a lot of folks in the world still
remember him he was a very highly
regarded monster rider
and there are other folks in the world
who still remember him so you're going
to be
seeing some maybe familiar characters
and really building on the legacy of
that character if you enjoyed that game
and again not how i would normally play
but i got places to be miss
all the legs i know all these little
sides side paths
and stuff we have to skip we're gonna
try to avoid fights as much as possible
[Music]
here really surprising just remember
like you're well this is what only the
first second area that
like we have and this is all in the demo
and again i will say
pick up the demo yeah the most open no i
mean on the
on the start screen you'd played more
than 10 hours so far into this
so that's it's very relaxing too i love
just honestly riding around
and enjoying the atmosphere it's so
beautiful there's just so much to dig
into
here let's see that's a little bit of a
dead end let's try
up this way so uh
for you guys i'd love to come back to
the conversation about
your your kind of levels of familiarity
with the franchise and what that does
yeah like jc i know you have gone deep
into
monster hunter rise i don't know what
your our count is right now but
you're coming at this as somebody who
spent a lot of time hunting monsters
yeah uh you know it's interesting
because like you know i was introduced
to the
monster hunter franchise by a friend
here actually nintendo
and we just started hunting together
he's like try this you'll like it
and so you know we started playing and
one thing led to another next to you and
i was just hooked
uh because i love helping other people
and all you do is just help other people
and it's so wholesome and it's fun um
but yeah um over time you start to learn
all these little details about the
monsters you get to know their names and
um all of that so it's really refreshing
to see
so many little call outs the a buttons
the sound effects
everything kind of lines up in this
monster hunter universe
that makes this a perfect complex to you
know
uh go ahead i love
sam in the background hey dude you got
to do you're doing great um
but yeah so again a really really
interesting and and i'll admit i
i am i'm really really interested in
playing the full game because i think
playing the demo absolutely sold me on
what
yeah what this game offers and i
definitely could use a good rpg right
about now
yeah and from my perspective like i love
rpgs grew up on rpgs
and have always been a little bit like
do i have the time to dive into
monster hunter like i hear people talk
about it and their passion is
immediately like you can totally tell
how much they love it
um but it's always seemed a little
intimidating uh
but i actually have to stop and check
out this what is where are we now
we are in a little feline borough sorry
i saw the icon on the map and i couldn't
resist
so this is a caravanner he's one of the
little felines who runs the quick travel
service that i used earlier so
he's got to stop here i'm not going to
travel but good to know that he's here
i've also got a face on this a little
healer here
the supported feline if i needed healing
she would help me out and she is
also just i mean look at how cute
i'm healed up right now but i just want
to say hi um
there's also a chest here i am not going
to steal from these adorable little
cuties i will leave it up to everybody's
own moral compass
you could what you could okay
would you want to look at yeah they are
no i'll just i'm just going to finish
what i was saying before which was
[Laughter]
take a break for the feline but um was
just that like i
have always been like i know that
monster hunter gameplay is very real
time
and very action based in in the you know
the main series
um and what i love about this is as an
rpg fan i have
the time to pick my strategies and
you know take you know uh you know kind
of things one step at a time in a
turn-based environment
um while i'm still getting all that full
monster hunter flavor
you know that that is present in the
rest of the series um
so yeah again like this may be the one
that
dive in on on other titles too like i'm
there we go thinking about checking
about rise
uh just because of the time i've spent
with this demo so and a lot of the
knowledge again everything you've seen
here uh it'll definitely help you even
i guarantee it we should hunt together
sometime i would
love that i love that and this game
actually has co-op as well so
you guys can party up in ryzen party up
here oh nice
so i won't say too much during this cut
scene but one thing i will mention
if you're interested in the look and
you're interested in the game check out
the trailers that have been released so
far
uh we had some content in the nintendo
direct that just showed as well
so you can get a look at some of the
later game content
it's really beautiful i'm sure he's
waiting for red to come home
that's what chief gara always said but
this red guy's not around anymore right
so why the truth is
once a monster forms a bond with a rider
it never forgets them
remember that strange light when
guardian ratha left
something must have happened then
otherwise guardian ratha would never
have abandoned the island
okay let's take a look around
yeah leave it to me my nose knows
there's something here
and if you've watched any of the trailer
content we're gonna see a character here
that is probably gonna look familiar
is it right
oh hi
i can't believe my eyes who are you
i'm sorry to say but this isn't red
oh of course
there's no way it could be
it's just those always look like reds
red was one of our leaders this is his
grandkid
huh red passed away a long time ago
i know it's just i
i actually came to see guardian rather
red gave me something to bring back here
something from red
whoa what was that
something's coming over there
[Music]
suddenly regretting missing all those
fights i could have earned some
guardian experience is dead why is it
acting so weird
what's going on
this looks probably bad buddy
please take this swizzled kinship stone
you might be able to use it to calm that
monster down
red's kinship stone how come you have it
red he wanted you to have it
take it
you ready for this yeah let's do it
right on
oh boy so this
is the next fight in the demo um
i i thankfully will not need to
embarrass myself here i don't think
because we are
close to running out of time so um i can
just
kind of pop through a round or two here
but uh jc since we're almost done
we could probably circle back to the
news that we've got to share about the
cross compatibility eh
ah yes i'm a little bit i'm sure a
little video will play
um and we'll start kind of talking about
some amiibo
um so generally speaking if you have
amiibo
uh from uh let's see from monster hunter
rise and you kind of tap them into this
game
i'll kind of wait for the uh and show up
yeah something like that you got a video
okay maybe you should wait for the video
should i wait
that's all right i mean while we're
waiting uh while we're waiting on uh
here um so the demo is gonna come out on
the 25th so very very soon
the game is going to launch on the 9th
so please do check it out
um i've been having a blast this is a
really really fun demo and i think
you're going to get a kick out of it
oh and it looks like the video is up
let's go yeah so if you basically if you
have
some of the some of the amiibo from uh
monster hunter rice you tap them in a
monster hunter stories too
uh you get some stickers um and those
stickers will look real familiar to you
and they'll be happy here uh and the
inverse is true
so if you tap in the monster hunter
stories two amiibo into
uh into you know monster and rise you
get stickers in that game
so yeah it's uh definitely something to
look forward to because i know i
definitely will uh
do the same as well as another little
point i want to make which
is if you have saved data
for this particular demo on your system
and you fire up
monster hunter rise it doesn't matter
which order it comes in and you talk to
senri the mailman
in monster hunter rise um he'll give you
a talisman
and that tells me that has tinship tells
me thank you very much um it basically
uh you get it also has a two
skills um the first one's like uh master
mounter which kind of helps you like
do your dodge counters a bit easier
helps fill that gauge a bit faster for
your writing gauge
and also wide range which i use a lot
which is basically you know you have a
lot of
items you use some helpful stuff and
then it shares that effect with the rest
of your teammates
so really cool and it's again it's free
i think sam already hit on the date but
just to remind you again
free demo lots of lots of good stuff
happening on june 25th
full game releases on july nine so we're
just
arriving yeah that's coming up good
summer really soon
and and with that being said again that
is all we have to show for you today on
just from us so thank you so much first
of all to
capcom for allowing us to show this
really awesome demo thank you to sam and
to ethan
uh it's great being with you guys once
again it's so much
good so great and uh and also to you out
there watching
thank you for sticking around you could
have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with us and we
appreciate that but don't go anywhere
because we have more stuff coming up
next we have a bit of a look to show you
for
some mario golf super rush so don't go
anywhere